well I've been on Tik Tok
again it's Michelle of L muffin Beauty
science chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
although these days I feel like what I
am is more of a misinformation
connoisseur I have plunged into the
depths of Tik Tok and I brought back
some
gleaming steaming piles of manure that
is one big pile of misinformation
just goes viral really easily on Tik Tok
it just hooks into that algorithm so
well last time I did skincare this time
I'm going to debunk Hair Care myths
using science I'll be talking about
silicone sulfates preservatives falah
Benzene washing your hair twice heat
protectants and more I've debunked a lot
of these on Tik Tok and Instagram before
but I can never really go into that much
detail cuz those are so short so here we
[Music]
go dmdm hydantoin is considered a
formaldahyde releaser which doesn't
sound so healthy for your scalp okay so
Dr Tony Yun is a holistic plastic
surgeon he's huge on every platform I've
heard that his plastic surgery stuff is
pretty interesting and informative but
he also talks a bit about beauty
products and it's just not correct he
pushes a lot of that clean Beauty pseudo
science maybe because he does have a
clean Beauty brand it could also be just
an overconfidence thing that some
doctors have this is a continuation of
that and this particular Tik Tok is
actually part of like my Tik Tok origin
story back in 2020 I came across this
and a bunch of other videos and they
annoyed me so much I had to join Tik Tok
so before we keep going I just want to
talk a little bit about medical doctors
some people say I'm a bit too mean to
medical doctors who are spreading
misinformation online but I do think
that they really should be held to a
higher standard I get really annoyed
because they do have the privilege of
being educated enough to know better and
I also consider myself being privileged
enough to be able to do a PhD so I also
hold myself to this higher standard I
also know a lot of doctors do a lot of
my friends in real life are doctors and
a lot of my misinformation debunking
friends online are also medical doctors
so this isn't like a blanket disc of
doctors it is just about the ones who
say a lot of
du a lot of doctors do use their
authority to build their platform and
again I mean I do too I think it is
valid to tell people where your
expertise is coming from what actually
informs your content and people just do
respect titles and it is kind of handy
because you know as an Asian woman who
looks younger than she is and I mean
I've got purple hair I get disrespected
a lot and just waving my PhD around has
become a bit of a shortcut to get people
to actually listen to what I say before
they dismiss me for very superficial
reasons it's kind of like a relatively
superficial reason that undoes some even
more superficial reasons anyway the
problem is if you do have that extra
Authority bias I really think you need
to be more responsible about what you
say that Authority bias that comes with
having a title being being a medical
doctor that really superpowers any
misinformation you spread and there are
a lot of doctors who kind of play that
up like they dress in Scrubs they film
in front of their wall of medical
diplomas and I really just think that
with great power comes great
responsibility dmdm hydantoin is
considered a formaly releaser which
doesn't sound so healthy for your scalp
okay so the way he says this is a little
bit weird like considered a falive
releaser it just is a falive releaser it
is how it work works dendam hydantoin is
a preservative like all of these other
preservatives he's also got these are
needed in products to kill microbes so I
mean they are killing living things and
so at some level they are also going to
be harmful to people the trick is to
have such a small amount that is fine
for people when they put it on their
skin but also will harm the microbes
when they're swimming in it so yeah
fatahi does maybe sound bad and it is
bad if you inhale a whole bunch of it it
does cause nasal cancers I've talked
about it before in my video on the not
so pretty documentary series on that
nail episode but if you have a small
enough amount and you are exposed to it
in the right way like on your skin
rather than up your nose then it is safe
this is something called Hazard versus
risk so Hazard is something that's
harmful in some way but the actual risk
how much in danger you are that also
depends on exposure so if your exposure
is really low even if the hazard is high
together that can mean that your risk is
still really low so you can look at my
video on clean Beauty which talks a lot
more about that I've got a toxicologist
there explaining all of these principles
so falah hiide is actually also in lots
of living things like we produce it
inside our bodies it's in things like
pears we actually produce about 50 g of
faly a day which is like 1/5 of a cup
it's not that great for us our bodies
have evolved a lot of systems to deal
with it and limit its damage but the
amount on your scalp is like a fraction
of of a milligram it is really just not
that big a deal and I mean he should
know this because he is a plastic
surgeon he's familiar with Botox and the
logic is exactly the same so Botox if
you didn't know is one of the most toxic
substances in the world possibly the
most toxic something like a few
kilograms of it can kill everyone on
Earth but at the same time millions of
people have had it injected into their
face and it's been fine because of
exposure it's being injected in a low
enough amount at the right place now
this thing where he says faty doesn't
sound so healthy toxicology and biology
isn't about how something sounds it's
not about you know the feels or The
Vibes I really hope as a doctor he is
not going on how things sound for like
freaking surgery I really hope he's
looking at actual evidence and it's
disappointing that he isn't here so he's
really just playing to people's fears
here this is really frustrating because
it is the kind of logic that antia
anti-science movements use if something
sounds bad it is bad don't bother
looking at the evidence just go with
your gut feel I have a very bad feeling
about this so one of the reasons I am so
passionate about clean beauty is that
there are lots of links between clean
Beauty and the antia movement especially
with the whole measles vaccine thing
with autism back in the early 2000s and
one of the links is actually for
Malahide if you look at infographics for
clean Beauty and anti effects they are
just like very very similar tiny amounts
of f Malahide are in lots of vaccines
and you see it all the time on these
like infographics it will say things
like you know this is so bad it's bad
for you gives you cancer you don't want
to inject it into your baby you also
just don't want to put it on your scalp
according to the same logic and it
drives me a bit mad that people who are
into public health don't really see this
as what I think is a huge problem we
have huge beauty stores like alter and
Sephora just teaching a really big chunk
of the population this logic from their
early teens this whole idea that if it
has for out hide then it is unclean and
you need to avoid it it's going to be
really hard to undo all this
indoctrination by the time someone is
having a baby and they're asked whether
or not they want to inject a vaccine
with a tiny tiny amount of fatte into
their precious baby and they're actually
is a class action lawsuit going on right
now all right so class action lawsuits
get brought up a lot in social media
posts about different ingredients the
thing is anyone can bring a class action
lawsuit that just doesn't really tell
you if if they have a good case and even
if they do end up settling and the
people end up getting a bunch of money
it's not an admission of guilt
settlements happen all the time for
other reasons like avoiding a long
protracted expensive lawsuit and just
all the bad publicity that gets wrapped
up into that so for these DM Damm hantu
and lawsuits it does mostly just seem to
be people with allergies there is a
small percentage of the population
allergic to most ingredients so for f
Malahide it seems to be somewhere around
1% of people so if you are allergic to
falah heide it can cause itching and
hair loss but that doesn't mean it's
causing hair loss for people who aren't
allergic allergies are when your body is
just overreacting to something that is
normally safe now I have noticed that
there's been a lot more hair loss
lawsuits lately with lots of Brands
whose formulas haven't actually changed
much in years maybe decades and I think
the explanation that makes the most
sense is the pandemic Co is linked to
hair loss and a lot of people even if
they haven't had Co they've been
stressed which is also linked to hair
loss and hair loss just varies over time
as well so people tend to lose more hair
in Spring and lose less hair in Autumn
there's also things like pregnancy so
there are a lot of things that can cause
hair loss and saying that it is
definitely linked to one thing like a
shampoo or a specific ingredient in a
shampoo that is just really difficult to
do without looking at science so it's
really just correlation isn't causation
I can't believe how long I've taken
debunking this 10-second video there's
something called brandolini's law which
is also called the BS a symmetry
principle basically it just says it
takes an order of magnitude like 10
times more effort to debunk
misinformation than to spread it and it
is always harder to debunk when it's
someone who you would expect to be well
informed like a medical doctor and then
on top of that there's just so many more
non doctor people spreading
misinformation so support me by liking
and subscribing I swear I didn't say
that just to get in this pitch there's
actually a really good reason your
shampoo bottle says rinse and repeat on
the back and no it's not just
manufacturer's way to sell more shampoo
but I used to think the same thing let
me take you over to my how shampoo works
poster and yes I made this cuz I'm a
nerd and I love talking about shampoo
but basically this is why it works okay
when you are H you know needing to
shower you have a dirty scalp you're
going to have sebum you're going to have
oil on it what happens is that when you
shampoo you're going to have these
little purple things that are called
surfactants they're going to attach
themselves to the dead skin cells the
oil the grime the dirt all of that and
it's going to create what's called a my
cell this my cell is hydrophobic and
hydrophilic and it's going to release
when the water that you wash it off with
touches that okay so then it's going to
wash way down the drain a lot of people
Tagg me in this video because she claims
that it's just how science works you
have to wash your hair twice so my PhD
is partly in super molecular chemistry
which is the science of how molecules
interact without actually going through
a chemical reaction which is what all of
this stuff is now I am all for making
your own diagrams when you don't like
the ones that already exist I do it all
the time but I don't love her
explanation and I wonder if this is
actually why she is confused when you're
washing your hair and you've got the
surfactant interacting with the oils it
actually breaks up into lots of little
emultion droplets which aren't really
called my cells but that is really just
a technicality it's not all lifting off
in one giant blob it's just lots of
little dots and it suspense before you
start washing it off it isn't like the
wood hits it and then it suddenly like
lifts off or something it doesn't
suddenly release because there is
already water around it's already
touching it it is already going to be
lifting off and turning into droplets
here's the thing your scalp is not
totally clean after this one process so
after most of those get washed away
there's still going to be a little bit
of dirt and grime and dead skin cells on
your scalp okay that's just how it is
and you need to repeat so at that point
you can get all of the oil surfactants
are going to create a my cell and then
the masel is going to wash it away and
at the end of your second wash you're
going to feel a huge difference
compared to the first wash there is
nothing in the science that says one
wash with surfactant can't lift off all
the oil and dirt it is just the same
chemistry as washing plates when you're
washing plates you don't necessarily
need to wash them twice sometimes you do
it depends on how dirty it is how dirty
your plates or your hair is it depends
on your Technique it depends on what
products you're using if you're using a
product that just isn't very good at
cleaning or if you didn't use enough of
the product even things like the
temperature of your water will make a
difference
so you might find that your hair is
better if you wash twice but most
shampoos are designed to wash off with
just one wash now I did get a bunch of
people asking me if I don't need to wash
my hair twice why do I get more foam on
the second shampoo so the reason you get
less foam is because the surfactants are
in charge of both lifting the oil off
your hair as well as forming foam so if
you have more surfactants tied up in the
oil you're going to have less to create
foam but the thing is this doesn't
actually tell you anything about whether
or not the SE washes is doing anything
so all this tells you is that in your
first wash you have some of these
surfactants tied up in the oil you have
less surfactants tied up in the oil in
the second wash but you could also just
have no oil even if the second wash was
doing nothing you would still get more
foam if you washed your hair a third
time and you got a lot more foam than
the second wash then that tells you your
second wash was doing something the
third wash tells you nothing about the
third wash the second wash foam tells
you nothing about the second wash and
it's interesting that she says this at
the start like all shampoos say to rinse
and repeats but most shampoos that I've
looked at in my collection most of them
say to repeat if necessary if they even
mention repeating at all someone in my
comments mentioned that the shampoo
bottle she's holding is manate which is
a multi-level marketing brand she is
selling it and I've noticed that manate
sellers tend to spread a bunch of
misinformation online I don't know if
it's officially sanctioned or if it's
just you know people being creative and
entrepreneurial but honestly from what
I've heard of this company I wouldn't
put it past them to just have this on
the shampoo to make you buy
[Music]
more so yeah this is an example of like
the bad manate tests that they've been
spreading the thinking which if you can
call it that is that if you get a cotton
bud and you put the heat protectant on
it and then try to light it on fire
it won't light if it's a good heat
protectant but that is not how heat
protectants work a hair stylist online
got her toddler to explain it and he
actually explained this really well so
I'm going to play that I'm going to
cover up his face cuz it's kind of weird
to have someone else's toddler in your
video hi your dressers just
because something isn't rarded that
doesn't mean that they're not heat
arestant heat isn't fire yes so that is
literally it if you have a heat
protection it spreads heat out really
nicely and so you're not getting hot
spots in your hair fire is combustion
it's something reacting with oxygen and
burning so cotton for example is
actually used in oven mitts it's really
good at protecting your hands from fire
but it's going to burn they are two
completely different properties of
substances most of the time what these
videos are actually showing is that some
products contain water which is really
good at not lighting and other things
will contain oil or alcohol and they
will light on fire it is just a test for
combustion so I guess the ironic thing
is that too much water is actually bad
in heat protectants because water can
absorb into hair and boil it doesn't
evaporate as easily as alcohol but it
boils a lot more easily than oil and so
what happens is inside your hair it can
boil explosively so it goes kind of like
popcorn and it causes something called
Bubble hair which is literally like
popcorn three High Street shampoos that
you need to avoid like the plague number
one head and shoulders there are much
better shampoos that you can use for
dandruff that you can get from your
local pharmacy Head and Shoulders
contain sulfates which can dry out the
scalp and over time leave your hair
looking dull and dry also Head and
Shoulders can lead to color fade outs if
you spent dollar dollar dollar on having
amazing dyed hair this may fade it a lot
quicker than you want it to go something
that I've noticed is so many of these
videos warning people to stay away from
particular hair care products they
always say things like avoid these like
the plague which I guess people aren't
really avoiding the plague but also
things like avoid at all costs which is
a really common thing I see I sort of
half expected her to say this I don't
know why I never hear this phrase in
real life and my conspiracy theory is
that they're usually about to recommend
a really expensive alternative that
maybe they are selling in their links
and so they kind of want to prep you
with the word cost anyway Head and
Shoulders is one of those brands that a
lot of people keep warning people about
and I think it is because it is a really
nice affordable brand and yes there are
other options for dandruff but Head and
Shoulders is a really solid choice they
are a Proctor and Gamble brand they
invented a lot of new technology around
getting zinc pythium which is the active
ingredient that kills the fungus that is
causing the dandruff they've got a lot
of tech on getting that to deposit on
the scalp so it is really not a bad
choice now sulfates is one of my like
passion topics they are not
automatically harsh and stripping I've
talked about it in my shampoo myths
video the reason is the way seant work
to clean your hair is a super molecular
process it is sort of like molecular
choreography all of these little
tadpoles are working together to lift
the oil off the hair I keep on showing
this diagram and the lead author of the
paper asley dmed me on Instagram so hi
if you are watching thank you again for
this diagram it is just so handy for
explaining cleaning so not all of these
pink tadpoles are the same and all these
surfactants are working together in the
product to lift off the oil in pretty
much every shampoo you get these days
you will see multiple surfactant and so
the sulfates if they have sulfates are
just going to be some of these pink
tadpoles so how much a shampoo strips
isn't just about whether or not it has
sulfates yes or no it's also about
everything else that's in there which is
the surfactant but also the other
ingredients that aren't shown in this
diagram like polymers they all interact
as well and some of these ingredients
can keep the sulfates from going deeper
into hair or deeper into skin so it's
about what the final combination of
everything is overall it's sort of like
Nicholas Cage movies you can't tell just
by whether or not it has Nicholas Cage
or if it's Nicholas Cage free whether or
not it will be a good movie Nicholas
Cage good or bad a challenge certainly
but not un solvable it's about
everything else in the movie like who
the director and the writer are now if
you do have colored hair like me I think
you would probably be better with a
color protection shampoo that is
actually optimized to protect your color
Head and Shoulders don't have one in
Australia anymore but someone told me
that they do have one in other count
trees and there's a Good Housekeeping
test where they tried lots of different
color protection shampoos the one that
stripped dye the least had sulfates in
it now I did get a lot of comments
saying that people love sulfates because
they get their hair clean and I do
appreciate the energy but it still isn't
about sulfates or not it is still the
overall formula that's important you can
make a really mild sufate shampoo you
can make a really stripping sufate free
shampoo number two Tres now these
products contain sulfates against dry at
the hair but also contain silicon which
can build upon the scalp and cause
itchiness and irritation of the scalp so
I would recommend not to use TreeSet so
silicones can build up on the scalp it's
just like any other conditioning
ingredient but generally it's not an
issue with shampoos there really isn't
that much conditioning in shampoos
there's really just enough silicones to
make your hair not tangle when you're
washing you do need a bit of
conditioning agent in shampoos otherwise
your hair gets really Tangled and matted
and damaged because when your hair is
wet the cuticle sticks up a bit bit more
it's going to be rougher it's going to
be a bit more fragile and you are moving
it around a whole bunch so it is really
prone to getting damaged if different
hair snag against each other and break
off bits of cuticle now most of the time
in shampoos it's not silicon that are
conditioning it's actually polymers
possibly because people got scared of
silicon I do see a bunch of people
saying why would I want a shampoo that
conditions I just want it to clean and I
get that but if you do try a shampoo
that doesn't have any conditioning
agents it is a horrible experience
number three OGX now this brand which is
quite popular and is available in most
drug stores has actually got an alleged
lawsuit against it now I'm not sure of
the ins and outs but I think it's
because of hair loss or hair thinning
now they do contain chemicals which can
be quite strong on the scalp and can
lead to irritation they do claim to be
sulfate free however but again I would
just avoid this OGX lawsuit is about F
Malahide I talked about that before but
it is kind of wild to me that we have
like a medical doctor here with a
stethoscope and scrubs she is an
Aesthetics doctor so I'm not sure what
she's doing with the stethoscope anyway
why would you not at least look it up
before people to avoid it like the
plague again it is just that lack of
responsibility that's really annoying me
having that doctor's endorsement really
does superpower the misinformation
people are more likely to believe it I
got this comment on a video and I don't
know if this person is joking or not but
this is literally how a lot of people
think and it's not necessarily a bad
thing we should be able to trust experts
but but a lot of these perceived experts
are spreading misinformation and
pretending they have the right expertise
to know more about it when they don't
and it is usually all these really
affordable brands that get all these
warnings against them and it's really
frustrating because these drugstore
products are good products and a lot of
the Alternatives that people are
recommending instead they don't do their
own R&D but they charge so much more and
it's just kind of gross and elst to me
that these people are trying to get
people to spend more money for a product
that will probably have less benefit and
yeah people do get higher commissions
and higher affiliate income of higher
price products also this is kind of just
hilarious to me but every time I debunk
one of these videos with a sidebyside du
it I get a whole bunch of comments
saying something like her hair is really
shiny your hair is really dull why would
I listen to you and this is just
hilarious to me because I think it's
pretty obvious that you know I'm East
Asian my natural hair color is black
bleaching is possibly the most damaging
thing you can do to your hair to get my
hair to this color I had to sit for a
full 9-hour workday at a hair salon that
specializes just in bleaching the crap
out of Asian hair so this was bleached
to a level 9 or 10 it is pretty much a
miracle that my hair is still attached
to my head before OLX really became a
thing a lot of hairdressers would just
refuse to do this a lot of hairdressers
still refuse to do this so it feels a
lot like saying Icelandic people know
more than Australians about sun
protection because Australians have more
sun damage and the amount of exposure
and the conditions that the hair SL skin
has gone through is just so different in
the two situations and honestly before I
did this to my hair it was a lot easier
to manage my hair was always really
shiny and it looked fine but I knew so
much less about hair then compared to
now and I'm not saying you have to have
super damaged hair to understand hair
but it does give you an extra incentive
to learn more about how to deal with
your hair anyway the two aren't
correlated it's a weird comment stop
using these products they are ruining
your hair do I even need to go into
detail batist is far too heavy to be
using on your hair frequently the reason
why it's an issue is cu it's really
difficult to completely shampoo out of
your hair unless you're using a detox
shampoo if this isn't washed out
properly it builds up on the scalp it
can block hair follicles and that can
lead to hair loss or lack of hair growth
if we look at what ingredients are in
batist I'll put them up here the first
three are gases butane isobutane and
propane so they're just going to
evaporate and disappear so will the
alcohol and the fragrance so the stuff
that's left on your scalp We've Got Rice
starch that's not that hard to wash off
your hair I think we've all seen rice
starch going down the drain when you
wash your rice cocoa hydroly keratin
this is little chunks of keratin protein
attached to fatty acids that's the cocoa
bit that's generally not that difficult
to wash off the cetrimonium chloride and
diero dimonium chloride these two are
cationic surfactants they're really
common in conditioners they are pretty
much the most basic type of conditioning
ingredient again they're not really
anything that special and they're not
something that won't wash out without a
detox shampoo she does kind of have a
point here which is that dry shampoo
might mean you're washing your scalp a
lot less and then yes buildup can happen
on your scalp and that can mess up your
hair follicles it can also mess up the
microbial balance on your scalp and this
is important because it's one of the
main causes of dandruff this is the
yeast and if you have too much of those
they can cause scalp irritation they eat
up things called triglycerides which are
part of your skin oils they spit out
fatty acid and those can be irritating
and that can all lead to inflammation
which can mess with hair growth but this
is with anything that you spray onto
your scalp it's not really the batist
itself that's an issue but people who
wash their hair less than they should
might be using batist a lot because it
is such a popular dry shampoo the only
Miracle about this is that it's still
being sold this is really really not
good for your hair it has insoluble
silicone in there insoluble silicone is
silicone that cannot be broken down by
water which means it's very very
difficult to wash out silicone is
essentially plastic if that builds up on
your hair and you're also heat styling
you're essentially melting your hair
just waiting for it to break off really
isn't a very good conditioner I know it
can make your hair feel great but it's
all just superficial okay there is a lot
here she just kind of rattled off a
whole bunch of really common myths about
silicon so I'm going to try to get
through these somehow so first off
silicons aren't plastic this stuff here
is dimethicone you can see it is a lot
more like an oil it's a liquid Plastics
are solid point two this is obviously
not in order silicones do not melt hair
I'm not entirely sure where this comes
from but there is a lot of stuff with
hairdresses saying that when they bleach
hair it heats up and then they can see
silicon dripping off which is an
observation but the explanation isn't
quite right the heating is probably from
metal irons in the hair these can come
from dyes or tap water and that's
reacting with some of the ingredients in
Bleach but it is not the Silicon doing
it silicons are really stable to heat
and that is why they're used in so many
heat protection products they won't
react and produce more heat so with
these silicon that are really unreactive
like dimethicone which is the main one
that people mention this with they can
only really get as hot as whatever hot
tool you're using and the reason they
work so well for heat protection is
because they don't react they form a
layer that helps spread out heat more
evenly it's sort of like when you're
using a frying pan versus if you're
directly cooking on a fire having that
extra layer there spreading out the Heat
it stops you from getting hot spots
where your hair will just start
decomposing well there are other bits of
your hair that are still too cold and
they're not being Stu they're not
actually curling or straightening or
whatever you're doing okay next Point um
it doesn't condition well because it is
just superficial superficial
conditioning is actually probably the
most important part of conditioning the
reason things that are on the surface
make your hair feel great is because
it's been smoothed out so when you're
touching your hair your skin all the
tiny microscopic little Jack dagger bits
in your skin they're not getting caught
on the rough bits of your hair and so
that means your Smooth hair is also more
protected it's not getting caught on
brushes and straighteners it's not
getting caught and getting stretched
which is one of the biggest causes of
the damage you get when you're grooming
your hair when you're brushing or
styling she also mentions soluble versus
insoluble silicones and I think this
might come from maybe the curly hair
method thing this thing in itself has
like a lot of layers first off it
doesn't matter if the silicones are volb
or not you don't need to wash out all of
your conditioner because conditioners
they don't form a continuous film on
your hair they form more sort of like
little blobs so it's not like your
conditioning layer is blocking stuff
from going in or out of hair it can just
stay there it's sort of like protective
paint on a drink bottle or something you
don't need to like scrub off all the
paint every time and apply more paint
you can just leave the paint on there
now ins soluble things wash off hair all
of the time so oils for example aren't
water soluble that is the whole point of
putting the surfactant in the shampoo
they have that oily partt which grabs
onto things that are not water soluble
water soluble also doesn't mean it comes
off the hair more easily so hair is
really good at something called hydrogen
bonding that means it forms these
relatively strong intermolecular
interactions and water is really good at
this as well so ingredients that
hydrogen bond more tend to dissolve
better in water so more hydrogen bonds
means that it mixes better with the
water and spreads out so hyaluronic acid
and citric acid both can form hydrogen
bonds that's why they are water soluble
and that's also how they stick to hair
but it can actually also mean that they
stick to hair too well so some of the
most like sticky Hair Care ingredients
that build up on hair are actually
charged and relatively water soluble
there was no way we were going to get
through a Tik Tok misinformation video
without Bobby this guy is Bobby Parish
he's also known as flave City he usually
talks about food and he talks a lot of
pseudo science there as well and there's
a whole bunch of food science people
that I'm going to put up here who I
recommend who have specifically debunked
him you know those commercials or the
A-list actors way waving their hair for
Head and Shoulders spoiler alert they
ain't using it and sometimes when you
can't read or pronounce ingredients it
doesn't mean they're bad but in this
case it does these two are harsh
preservatives that are known allergens
skin irritant and neurotoxins I'm sorry
put it back it's kind of nice that he
finally admits for a change that being
able to pronounce a word just doesn't
mean very much so these ones are pretty
easy for me methyl isolone methyl chloro
isolone but I cannot pronounce Botanical
names like raspberry is rubus ID idus
Aus a carry plant is Maria
COI anyway I'm pretty sure it is better
for me to eat raspberry and Curry leaves
than it is for me to eat a whole bunch
of these two ingredients and I am
actually personally allergic to these so
I kind of feel this these are C
preservatives but they're being phased
out because when they were introduced
they sort of caused this so-called
epidemic of allergy and that word
epidemic is is actually used in the
peer- review journals some authors have
actually suggested that these became
more common in products because people
like Bobby were freaking everyone out
about parabens like what he was doing in
my last set of videos parabens actually
won the title of non-allergen of the
year in 2019 because they are relatively
non-allergenic compared to these
ingredients that might have replaced
them but again even though they are a
more common allergen if you're not
allergic to them you don't really need
to avoid them but these two do tend to
cause you should develop allergies to
them and they're kind of common so if
you do feel itchy with a lot of shampoos
and laundry detergents you might want to
look into that again he is using the ewg
database like last time they are a
really crap Source I went into tons of
detail about them in my last
misinformation video but basically they
are very much in the business of selling
fear their whole shtick is a bit like
please be scared of all these common
things but conveniently we are the only
people protecting you against them every
time you go on their website they just
just give you all these popups for
donations and they seem to have a lot of
funding from the organic industry so
obviously having this sort of database
of ingredients to watch out for is just
ignoring the whole idea of Hazard not
being like Risk the whole idea of dose
and exposure again it is this antia
logic and it is hard for me to believe
that they're not operating in bad faith
like I mentioned last time they kept on
going on with the whole vaccines cause
autism thing well after it was very
obvious that the whole wake field study
was just BS now the funny thing here is
is he does mention neurotoxicity if you
look at the thing he's showing it
actually says that it is a low risk if
you look it up in their database and
actually click on it it says that it is
on inv vatro test of mamalian cells so
in other words they must have gotten
some neurons out of some mammals and
then chucked it into like a little bath
of Mi and again it is a matter of
concentration and exposure the chance of
having like your brain cell swimming in
mi after you use a shampoo is just super
low the ewg have gten so lazy with their
referencing or maybe they just got sick
of people looking up the studies and
critiquing them because like open
scientific literature and then their
data sources are like open scientific
literature SL peer-reviewed literature
that is just like we looked it up on
Google and then they've got nlm 2012
PubMed online scientific bibliography
data that is literally like saying your
source is Google search but it's worse
because it's like Google search from
2012 anyway I found the study it is on
rat brain cells and the concentration of
Mi where they saw an effect was 100
microl so I got out my little calculator
because you know brandolini's principle
I'm going to have to do way more work
than bobb's doing it converts to 0.01%
Mi now in 2010 the US limited Mi to
0.01% now this was a cosmetic ingredient
review recommendation it's not like a
binding law but it is the sort of thing
that you follow if you're a big brand
unless you really want to open yourself
up to litigation so if we have this
maximum recommended concentration your
brain brain cells would have to be
swimming in the shampoo only diluted by
less than 10 times so a Big Blob of
shampoo in your hand is 5 G so you would
have to be using less than 1/5 of a cup
of water with that giant blob to get
that concentration anyway I would avoid
the ewg and anyone sighting it like the
plague I would avoid them at all costs
it absolutely blows my mind that so many
women do not know this but there is an
ingredient in pretty much every shampoo
that is destroying your hair it's called
table salt that stuff is in your shampoo
and it's also drying out your hair and
the crazy thing is it's in almost every
single shampoo I've looked at over 2,000
shampoos and at least 85% of them had
table salt in it if you don't believe me
go to your bathroom right now check your
shampoo if you see the ingredient sodium
chloride in there then that is table
salt this one is just kind of hilarious
to me like we are really scraping the
bottom of the barrel here we're trying
to freak people out about salt so yeah
sodium chloride is used in a lot of
shampoos because it is a really good way
of thickening up some surfactants so it
is some particular anionic surfactants
like sulfates basically anionic
surfactants are negatively charged and
the ions from the salt will interact
with these heads of the anionic
surfactants and it changes how they're
arranged so it makes the mels inside
your shampoo sort of turn into long
noodle shaped Mells and those get
tangled up more um that means that it
becomes a lot thicker they kind of like
get tangled up in each other before they
get poured out and so you end up with a
blob in your hand instead of like water
it's really cool and neat but the amount
of salt you need is actually really low
it's usually like 1% or perhaps even
less even sweat has more salt than this
sea water has like three times more plus
you also dilute your shampoo before you
put it in your hair and then you wash it
out after maybe a couple of minutes
maximum so it's not like your hair is
soaking in the salt the thing is when
you use a product that contains table
salt it will over time cause your scalp
to dry out and this can cause fleaky
scalp hair loss and not only that it
also dries out your strands which can
cause split ends breakage and just
brittle hair overall your hair is
getting attacked from all sides so yeah
your hair is not soaking in the salt
your scalp isn't soaking in it either
but even if your scalp was soaking in
the salt the reason that salt dries out
your skin is because of Osmosis that's
when water is getting pulled out because
the liquid outside your cells has like
more concentrated salt than the liquid
inside your cells but your diluted
shampoo is really not that salty if it
is drying out your scalp it's probably
other things in there like the
surfactant and just the water from your
shower maybe it's like warmer and just
washing out the oils from your scalp
that's going to be making a much bigger
difference than like the tiny tiny
sprinkle of salt okay we're doing it
let's talk about the 1.5 million dry
shampoos that have been recalled in the
US and Canada this past week if you
haven't seen tons of dry shampoos right
now are being recalled for having a
cancer-causing ingredient in them called
Benzene so yeah this video was back from
the recall of dry shampoo because there
were traces of benzene found in them a
whole bunch of products have been
recalled sunscreens as well and hand
sanitizers and they're almost all
because of one lab called valesa I've
talked about the sunscreen recall in
another video that breaks it down in a
lot more detail but in short the lab
says a lot of really questionable things
that make it really sound like they're
trying to fear manga I might do a longer
video breaking down the background
behind this lab and some of their pretty
dubious things I don't know maybe a bit
later but the amounts of benzene found
in these products were really low but
like with foral heart it is pretty easy
to freak out about Benzene if you don't
know a lot about it back with the
sunscreen story a lot of dermatologists
were posting really fearmonger videos
based on that Valley Shore press release
because that press release itself was
pretty fearmonger now I don't really
blame people for freaking out a bit when
you first hear these sorts of stories
but you should really do a fact check
when these stories come out before you
throw out your products maybe just put
them in the back of a cupboard for a
while until more info comes up and it
gets a bit clearer and you should
definitely not film a video warning all
of your many followers about it now if
you don't know anything about Benzene
it's a chemical that's normally found in
car Admissions and gasoline it's been
found to cause temporary symptoms of
anemia memory loss skin irritation but
the most concerning it's a carcinogen
which means it's a cancer causing agent
so all of the recalls were done out of
that whole abundance of caution thing
the brands all go to lengths to say that
the amounts of benzene weren't expected
to cause any harm and the valish short
data does actually support that again
check out my older video on Benzene and
yes car emissions are one of the big
sources of exposure if you want to drop
your Benzene exposure the best thing to
do is actually just not to park your car
in a garage that's attached to your
house even if you inheld all of the
benzing coming out of one of these
products which is unlikely because you
know spray products go into the air not
just all into your lungs it is still
less exposure than breathing City air
for half a day so all of these effects
she's talking about like anemia memory
loss skin irritation Cancer all of these
are from occupational exposures to much
higher amounts of benzines again the
dose is really important for your actual
risk it's not from these tiny amounts
you getting from a hairspray and not
only are these aerosol cans causing us
to inhale this stuff but your scalp
actually absorbs things into the
bloodstream in just 26 seconds so that
crap is all up in your bloodstream I'm
not really sure where this 26 seconds
like factoid comes from but Benzene
isn't easily absorbed through your skin
or your scalp most of the exposure you
get is mostly through inhalation and
there was actually a study where some
dermatologists got annoyed enough to
look at the blood levels of benzine
measured in people who use different
amounts of sunscreen and they found that
there was just no connection between how
much sunscreen you used and how much
benzing you have in your blood which
again given how much Benzene has been
found in these products it's just not
really that surprising and take a look
at the first few ingredients on your dry
shampoo I'm willing to bet it's either
propane butane or isobutane now how this
crap is even allowed in our beauty
products beats me but let me give you a
little history lesson so you can kind of
understand how messed up beauty products
in the US are there is nothing wrong
with these ingredients they are all
propellant gases that push the dry
shampoo out of the can and they're not
toxic at sensible mounts just you know
don't Huff your can of dry shampoo
they're hydrocarbons and they're the
same stuff that you get in like hot pot
gas cans and in cigarette lighters but
this just really has nothing to do with
Benzene I think she's just kind of gr
down like this scary names Rabbit Hole
there has not been a law as to what Cann
not go in our beauty products in the US
since
1938 84 years ago and the us only has 11
ingredients banned from our products
whereas the UK has over 1,300
ingredients banned from their products
something is just not adding up here
like why there are so many myths about
us versus EU sluk regulations I've
talked about some of these before in my
video on EU versus US sunscreen
regulation but this whole 11 versus 1300
band ingredients thing this just really
doesn't tell you much unsafe ingredients
are banned in both regions and basically
these lists are just examples of
ingredients that would make a product
unsafe to my understanding the reason
the eu/ UK list is longer is mostly just
historical and political reasons when
the UK was part of the EU they used the
EU list and then since brexit they sort
of split it and now the UK list is
slowly sort of like evolving and
changing compared to the EU one
basically when the different countries
banded together to form the EU there was
like a lot of smooshing of regulations
and so that's why you find really weird
stuff on that list like things like jet
fuel and radioactive materials so it's
just like the EU has a lot more examples
and a lot of these examples have never
actually been in cosmetics they're just
included for weird historical reasons
and the FJ has issued warnings for
products that contain lots of
ingredients that aren't on this 11 band
ingredients list so clearly there are
more than 11 band ingredients things
like prostag gland and analoges and
those are eyelash growth ingredients
that have been found out side effects
they what's in B mat Prost and the thing
is all of the ingredients she's
mentioned in this video are allowed in
EU and UK products like butane propane
isobutane are commonly found and even
traces of benzene are allowed and having
a recall is actually a good thing so
notice that the US and Canada did have
recalls but the EU and the UK didn't and
this isn't because there's no Benzene in
those EU and UK products based on how
the Benzene got into the products it's
probably in lots of different countries
products as well I know people who work
in EU regulations and they've mentioned
that the US does have a more litigious
culture and that's maybe why the
products are so similar in both regions
even though the regulations do look
quite different but there are new
regulations coming into the US called
MRA and this will be nice because it
does make the regulations more similar
to the EU the biggest problem with the
US regulations that I've heard from
regulatory people is that the
regulations are pretty unclear so it's
hard for smaller Brands to really
understand what they can and can't do
what are good practices when making and
launching Cosmetics a lot of those like
homemade Kitchen products that you see
from small brand selling on places like
Etsy they are sort of like the beauty
equivalent of pink sauce there's just
not a lot of you know normal safety
practices going into making those and
this is a lot less of a problem in
Europe because you do need to register
any products that you sell so there is a
sort of at least basic gatekeeping that
stops a lot of people from just
launching weird unsafe products again I
think I've managed to make a video that
is like way too long on this I don't
know how I managed to keep all this to
like oneish minute when I was debunking
them on Tik Tok there are just a lot of
layers to all of these myths but yeah a
lot of these videos have had millions of
views and it is really quite scary how
this like perfect mix of fear and short
explanations just really hooks into
social media algorithms it's really easy
to get people's attention in a short
time span with this sort of content and
most people do care about their friends
and family so when they see these they
will forward it to them and make sure
you know they aren't harming themselves
and all of this sharing and saving is
just rewarded really well by all the
platforms so I guess the message here is
just be really careful when you're
sharing scary videos even if you are
doing it with good intentions which I'm
sure most people are I mean you can with
me so I can find out more about them and
debunk them but you know don't share
share it if it's something that's scary
or surprising that is like an automatic
red flag for misinformation it's not
always the case because scary stories
are sometimes true but most of the time
if something is surprising that means
that it isn't really supported by the
body of evidence it's not a robust
finding that's been confirmed again and
again which is how science works also
look for the consensus of relevant
experts and yes we did just see some
people who seem like experts sharing
this information but a lot of the time
medical doctors on social media aren't
really automatically experts on things
like toxicology and cosmetics those
aren't really topics that they learn in
any sort of depth in med school and
again there are huge teams of scientists
working at a lot of these companies the
chance that someone with no training or
expertise can look something up on an
app and find out it's toxic in 5 seconds
it's just really not something that all
of these scientists have missed or
they're staying quiet about it's just
really really improbable that there's
this huge conspiracy going on so most of
the time if a bunch of relevant experts
are overwhelmingly saying the same thing
it is probably going to be true based on
the current evidence if you see videos
on Tik Tok and Instagram that need
debunking please send them to me of
course it would be great if you follow
me on those platforms as well if you
enjoyed this video click the like and
the Subscribe teach the algorithm that
this is what you like seeing also let me
know what other myths you see all the
time that you want me to debunk
especially if it's on silicons I feel
like I could probably make a whole video
just on silicone myths if you want to
watch more myth busting videos I have a
whole playlist here if you want
something a bit less infuriating I also
have a whole bunch of cosmetic science
videos